michael bloomberg is hit with the
tsunami of opposition research democrats
freaked out over the continuing insanity
of the burning campaign and Barack Obama
leaves Joe Biden out to dry I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
today's Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your online activities
shouldn't be public protect yourself
that expressvpn comm slash man I hope
you had a wonderful president stay tuned
be President stage to be George
Washington's birthday why would we
possibly be celebrating James Buchanan
or Jimmy Carter and why would those be
things Woodrow Wilson if president
Bernie Sanders were thing why should we
have a day for Bernie Sanders president
says about George Washington the
greatest of all American presidents but
let's move on to the Democratic
primaries where it looks like an open
communist may in fact become the
Democratic nominee there are some new
polls out of Nevada there's also a brand
new national poll both of them showing
Bernie Sanders in the lead so we begin
with this poll out of Nevada the Nevada
poll this is done by a democratic
polling group called data for progress
apparently they have a fairly good
record in predicting at these things and
they have Sanders way the hell out ahead
way ahead Sanders up 19 points in this
data for progress poll and then the rest
of the Democratic candidates all
clustered in within a 1 or 2 point
margin you got Warren at 16 we were
judging 15 and Biden at 14 now Biden
basically needs to finish second here if
Biden finishes third he's gonna continue
to slide in South Carolina finishes
second he can say my candidacy is a
little more durable than at least it
appears to outsiders and therefore he's
gonna go on he's gonna win in South
Carolina and then his campaign will be
just fine that's the the basic idea here
but the fact remains that Joe Biden has
been sliding and he has been sliding
quite badly now the great hope for Biden
is that he does well among Nevada
Hispanic Democratic voters there's a new
Telemundo poll out of Nevada Democratic
Hispanic voters it's got Biden at 34
Bernie at 31 and then bootie drugs
Warren and Klobuchar are all in single
digits so way the hell ahead Biden and
Bernie Bernie showing strong in Hispanic
Nevada caucuses also presumably bernie
is rising in a lot of the minority polls
in places like South Carolina which
brings us to the national polls so there
is a new national poll out and the
national poll shows that Bernie Sanders
is up double digits AB double digits
over the rest of the field and bad news
for Joe Biden who has been collapsing
nationally in front of Bernie Sanders in
second place according to this new
national poll
believe it or not is Michael Bloomberg
this is an NPR Marist Poll it's
Berni at 31 Bloomberg at 19 Biden at 15
Warren at 12 and Klobuchar are not now
that a couple things about this poll
that are worthy of note first off it
demonstrates that nobody cares about
people to judge right Buddha judge is
not even on the screen in that NPR
Marist at national poll so for all of
the talk about people to judge he is a
non-factor and this has been the reality
for people to judge nationally the man
did well in Iowa he did well in New
Hampshire and no one cares about him he
has never surpassed I believe 14 percent
in a national poll he has never had the
kind of momentum that would propel him
to a nomination and in the last couple
of polls he is actually down in fifth
place fifth place in the national
polling that's according to the
Economist YouGov poll that has Sanders /
Biden by 4 percent that one is from
February 11th and then the brand new NPR
PBS Marist Poll has Sanders way the hell
out ahead in front of Joe Biden at 15
Bloomberg at 19 Warren at 12 Buddha
judge 8 okay so Buddha judge is a
non-factor nationally Klobuchar is a
non-factor nationally basically this is
now a three-person race
this is Bloomberg Biden and Sanders and
the question is going to be whether
Biden completely fades in Nevada and
falls apart and then Bloomberg supplants
him on Super Tuesday
because if Biden does not win South
Carolina he is toast he must win South
Carolina you cannot keep finishing
seconds as the former vice president of
the United States with heavy support
going in leading every national poll and
leading in a lot of the polling in Iowa
and New Hampshire and then show his week
as Biden has done on the actual ground
and hope to continue in this race now
all Michael Bloomberg's out there
spending hundreds of millions of dollars
on advertising will get to Michael
Bloomberg in just a minute here okay but
there's another thing about this poll
that is telling it's not just Biden's
slide which has been ongoing for a while
it's not just Bloomberg's rise which has
also been ongoing for a while Mike
Bloomberg I mean if you watch Hulu if
you watch any if you watch YouTube if
you watch any place that allows ads
you're very very likely to see how
Michael Bloomberg and I believe I have
personally seen three or four Michael
Bloomberg ads at this point I don't
think I've seen any ad from any other
candidate it's just been Michael
Bloomberg ads the man is spending an
enormous amount of money and he is
getting tremendous earned media as well
because of this media rise that he has
seen in terms of in terms of the polling
but the big story in that NPR PBS Marist
Poll is Bernie showing above 30 that is
a major thing because one of
sort of presuppositions was that Bernie
would not be able to consolidate support
such that he gets to 50% in any of these
primaries remember the Democratic party
primaries are proportional and
representation not like the Republicans
it's not a winner-take-all system so if
Bernie wins 25 and Bloomberg wins 23 in
a state well that means that they're
basically gonna split the delegates
evenly that's a big problem for Bernie
if he wishes to win the nomination on
the first ballot now it's my belief that
if Bernie walks into the nominating
convention with the most delegates even
if he does not have a majority if he has
a plurality of the delegates gonna be
very difficult for the Democratic Party
higher echelon not to give Bernie the
nomination because his people are also
the most likely to walk away from the
convention and simply say we're not
gonna vote for whomever the alternative
Democratic nominee is with that said
Bernie starting to pick up some of these
consolidating votes right Bernie up at
31% that means that Biden plus Bloomberg
right which is the quote-unquote
moderate wing of the party they're only
pulling in that NPR PBS Maris Paul had a
combined 34 percent bernie is at 31 okay
which demonstrates a fair bit of
durability for the Bernie Sanders
campaign which has got to be scaring the
living hell out of the Democratic Party
upper echelon because again they look at
Bernie and they say this guy that
there's there's no way that this guy can
win a national election
I mean his campaign for all the talk
about how his campaign is drawing these
huge crowds and it is in Tacoma
Washington yesterday he drew 17,000
people to see an old commie talk to them
about Nostrum from the 1930s I mean it's
an incredible number 17th I mean he's
running Trump like crowds those are huge
crowd 17,000 people in Tacoma Washington
and he's gonna basically run on the same
platform that Trump did which is I'm
building a movement I'm gonna bring in
new voters know what the what the Trump
team got wrong about 2016 is that really
was not about cortical building movement
if you actually look at the numbers
Donald Trump performed exactly
I mean exactly like every Republican
nominee since about 2000 he performed
like George HW in 2000 and 2004 he
performed like John McCain in 2008 he
performed like Mitt Romney in 2012 he
was separated by at most a point or two
in all of the key swing states the big
deal was not the Trump mobilized a new
party base the big deal is
he showed up to vote for Hillary Clinton
well Bernie seems to be making the same
mistake he thinks he's gonna turn out
this whole new base but the problem is
there gonna be a lot of people who do
not show up to vote for Bernie
specifically because he is so radical I
think the party's up rational
understands this James Carville of
course has made this absolutely clear
and this is why right now the big
question is does Joe Biden undergo that
final fate and do we end up with Michael
Bloomberg picking that up you can see
the ONC's I mean the angst inside the
Democratic Party is truly astonishing at
this point we're gonna get to this in
one second first let us talk about
cowboy boots now you look at me do I
look like a cowboy do you I know that no
I do not look like a cowboy to you I'm
about as urban a Jew as it is possible
to be and yet I do love cowboy boots I
do love them there's only one problem
it looks garish and ridiculous for me to
be wearing the cowboy boots that have
you know all of the stitching on them
looks like I'm gonna go to a rodeo or
something that's not my look okay it's
inauthentic but I will tell you about a
great pair of cowboy boots supremely
comfortable and they look good on
somebody like me and they look good on
you too because they look good on
everybody I mean they're subtle they're
awesome they're comfortable and I can
even pop my jeans over the top of the
cowboy boots and they basically look
like hush puppies I mean that they're
just fantastic so Kovas cowboy boots are
hand made with high-quality full-grain
leather by world-class boot makers is to
Kovas they're built to be comfortable
right out of the box for every occasion
at home in the office out on the town
with tons of timeless styles Tuco's are
designed to be as fashionable 50 years
from now as they are today and they're
really subtle they're really great
they're not loud in any way Tacomas cuts
out the middleman sells direct to you
and an honest price that is truly
amazing for this level of quality boots
are extraordinarily versatile or you can
wear them in so many situations you can
wear them on the jobsite you can wear
them when you are out on the town you
can wear them to the office
these boots do it all for you there
really aren't one-stop shop for you plus
shipping returns exchanges free and easy
in addition to cowboy boots stick office
makes leather duffels men's jeans belts
billfolds card cases and more everything
you get from tacomas comes with the same
calculated approach in quality standards
that hold true to everything they do so
my wife one time I brought home this
pair of cowboy boots and she was like
there's no way you are ever wearing
these ever ever ever I brought home to
Cove us and she's like okay you're
allowed to wear those do what I did get
yourself a pair of Tacomas cowboy boots
today at Tech ovis comm slash Ben that's
te Co VA s comm slash man ladies makes a
great gift your husband Tec
vis comm slash Penta Kovas comm slash
Bennigan's that's two Kovas comm such a
great looking boots go check them out
right now as I say the Democratic Party
is trying desperately to either revive
Joe Biden's campaign or get him out of
the way and these two things are
mutually exclusive on the one hand they
want Joe Biden to stick in the race to
stop Bernie on the other hand if Joe
Biden is collapsing it they want him out
as fast as possible which is basically
why it is South Carolina or bust if he
does not win South Carolina where
Bloomberg is not on the ballot Joe Biden
is toast
his candidacy is over he can go home
good night
it means he is not won presumably a
single delegate for the ninth straight
race where he's run for president I mean
talk about a lackluster candidate
unbelievable ya know malarkey apparently
according to Greg Schulz Biden's
campaign manager he convened a
conference call with supporters on
Friday afternoon to outline a path
forward following two bruising losses in
Iowa New Hampshire this is the New York
Times reporting the campaign mr. Schultz
made clear on the call was banking on
finishing in at least second place in
the upcoming Nevada caucuses a contest
that will offer the first major test of
Biden's assertion he can uniquely
assemble a diverse coalition left unsaid
Nevada will also show whether Biden the
former VP can revive his campaign after
his first two finishes sends his
national poll numbers plummeting put his
donors on edge and jeopardized his
standing even his perceived firewall
state of South Carolina
Schultz head first would be wonderful
but us getting a second place I think
does the work we need to do to win South
Carolina we win South Carolina we're
gonna bend it the first four contests
likely with a delegate advantage he says
I think the Democratic Party will sigh a
collective sigh of relief when he
finished second or better in Nevada
these caucuses are happening on Saturday
there is a debate before that and the
big story debate is not gonna be Joe
Biden according to Megan Jones political
strategist in the state who worked for
the execrable Harry Reid
she says Biden's ground game has been
here a while had staffed her for a long
time similar to Iowa they took things
for granted that he was the front-runner
they did a 99 percent name ID
they've been quickly making up for lost
time because they know now it's a
make-or-break situation
apparently Biden's campaign has
redeployed staff from later voting Super
Tuesday states lend extra manpower in
Nevada he does need a strong showing in
Nevada or he is finished and you can see
the Democratic columnist freaking out
because they understand now that Joe
Biden may have actually prevented a
better moderate from changing the race
David Leonhart who used to be a reporter
over the New York Times now just writes
these bad
column says apiece today titled did
Biden scare off our next president he
says imagine the race of other Democrats
had not overreacted this is last year a
different version of the scenario
happened that was in 2016 right in 2016
everybody stay doubts they thought
Hillary would get the nomination said
last year a different version of this
scenario happened this time in the
moderate wing of the Democratic Party
Mitch Landrieu Duval Patrick Michael
Bloomberg skipped the race at least
initially much as Clinton had scared off
potential candidates in 2016
Biden did so in 2020 by now the lesson
from his history should be playing if
you want to be President and you have an
opportunity to run you shouldn't let
another candidate keep you from running
in the primaries with the current
campaign mired in uncertainty I think
some Democrats and pundits are missing
this lesson instead it's become common
to talk about the damage that Biden
supposedly did to this field
he says the early voting suggests this
analysis is more wrong than right the
problem wasn't Biden it was the way
other Democrats overreacted to him they
believed that he would basically run the
field then it would be over and so
nobody jumped in and that of course is
true meanwhile you have Eugene Robinson
over at the Washington Post similarly
complaining that the Democrats are
attacking each other and finishing
themselves off early he says somebody
eventually is going to win the
Democratic nomination if the candidates
are sincere when they say this is the
most important election of our lifetimes
and ousting Trump must be top priority
how does it make sense to generate so
much fodder for Trump campaign ads in
the fall so he's freaking out because
the Democrats are all attacking each
other and ruining each other now the
real reason Democrats are attacking each
other and ruining each other is because
Bernie Sanders is a bleep show of a
candidate he truly is now that doesn't
mean can't win I would say right now he
has about a 40 percent shot of being
President to the United States Bernie
Sanders I mean if he were up against
Trump I would give Trump 60/40 odds to
beat Sanders in a general election
matchup but 40 percent ain't bad for an
octogenarian communist who's been
useless for six decades living off the
government teat that's a pretty solid
pretty solid shot of being President of
the United States but the chaos in the
Sanders campaign and at his event none
of this shows particularly well on TV so
for example there was a brawl that broke
out at a Bernie Sanders rally in
Colorado according to CBS local a fight
broke out in the middle of the Bernie
Sanders rally on Sunday evening at the
Colorado Convention Center the
Democratic presidential candidate
rallied thousands of supporters in
Denver
a campaign stopped before the March 3rd
Colorado primary CBS 4s news camera was
capturing video of the event when two
men began fighting apparently I pushed
through a metal barrier and they
grappled with each other one man knocked
the other down onto the ground after
lifting him up it was good times at this
Bernie Sanders rally eventually it was
broken up but here's a little bit of
that video so that's good stuff
happening at the Bernie Sanders rally
and they meanwhile at another Bernie
Sanders rally topless protestors who
were Bernie supporters showed up at
Bernie's rally so two women took off
their shirts and shockingly they still
weren't the biggest boobs on the stage
cuz Bernie was up there in any case here
was here was Bernie Sanders being
interrupted by topless women who were
shouting about animal rights while
pouring liquid upon themselves I'm here
to ask you to stop popping up the dairy
industry and there are the topless women
showing up right there pouring liquid on
themselves which is a look right there
this is the yeah most excited Bernie's
been for a while in any case this is his
campaign okay because his campaign they
are Bernie supporters right they weren't
there to protest Bernie they like Bernie
they opened up their little statement
about how much they like Bernie Bernie's
their guy okay because Bernie is a
radical here here's the problem
Bernie Sanders is campaign is filled
with crazy people I mean really not
everybody who votes for Bernie is gonna
be crazy
there are lots of people who are not
crazy who are voting for Bernie I know
some people who couldn't vote for Bernie
I mean I may think that their politics
are crazy but they're not crazy but all
the crazy people are supporting Bernie
Sanders not everybody who supports
Bernie is crazy all the crazy people are
supporting Bernie Sanders okay and and
so the Democratic Party looks at that
and they go this is this is nuts and
Sanders trying to change his image is a
complete fail Sanders released an ad I
mean this is just insulting bullcrap and
I realized to stop myself there Bernie
released an ad in which he says he is
proud to be Jewish and then he
juxtaposes this with Charlottesville hey
Bernie trying to play on his ethnically
Jewish roots while being a lifelong
agnostic who recently has suggested that
he has found religion again meanwhile
surrounding himself with blatant vicious
anti-semites who campaigned for him like
Ilhan Omar and Linda Sarsour
and Rashidah Talib spare me spare me now
I want to hear about Bernie being proud
to be Jewish unless I'm also gonna hear
about no I'm Chomsky being proud to be
Jewish it turns out there a lot of Jews
people who are ethnically Jewish who
don't give two craps about Judaism who
are perfectly willing to put the State
of Israel in a dangerous international
position and to support anti-semitism
around the world so long as it services
the broader goals Bernie is one of these
people for him to pretend that he is
quote unquote proud to be Jewish in any
serious way proud to be Jewish how and
for what reason
exactly so Bernie cut this ridiculous ad
my father's family
was wiped out by Hitler in the Holocaust
I know about what crazy and radical and
extremist politics mean I learned that
lesson is a tiny tiny child when my
mother would take me shopping and we
would see people working in stores who
had numbers on their arms because they
were in Hitler's concentration camp I am
very proud of being Jewish and that is
an essential part of who I am as a human
being what we are seeing right now the
thing that an American was diamond all
over the world
the rise in weird Bernie then why are
you campaigning with open anti-semites
and anytime you'd like to disassociate
from Linda Sarsour and Jeremy Corbyn and
and all of the rest of the anti-semitic
Left anytime he wants to do that I'm
perfectly willing to hear it any time
now what's that deafening silence oh
yeah that's that's burning my favorite
part of that is where he's they're
showing video of the of the Nazi
concentration camps and and and
Holocaust and he says that he
understands the dangers of vicious
radical politics really does he cuz I'm
he was campaigning he was like out there
shirtless in the Soviet Union in 1987 so
I'm not sure he understands it I'm
really not sure by the way Soviets not
famous for their wonderful treatment of
the Jews I don't remember Bernie being a
loud and proud supporter of Jewish
immigration from the Soviet Union which
was a major cause by the way in the
1970s and early 1980s
and because this kind of stuff is
ridiculous which is why Bernie will
indeed be vulnerable to trump and you're
seeing some of the ads taken out against
Bernie we'll get to those in just one
second first let us talk about the bad
experiences that you've had I know
you've had bad experiences the bad
experiences that you've had in the past
with your auto parts stores so something
breaks in your car and your first move
is you got to go to the local auto parts
store there's only one problem you go to
the local auto parts store they don't
have what you're looking for if they do
have it's a generic part then fit your
car quite properly it's not the best
part and it's overpriced why not just go
to Rock Auto comm use the Internet it
makes everything better
chain stores have different different
price tiers for professional mechanics
and do-it-yourselfers alike but
rockauto.com doesn't even require
membership or account login rockauto.com
always offers the lowest prices possible
rather than changing prices based on
what the market will bear like airlines
do I spend up to twice as much for the
same parts the rockauto.com catalog is
unique remarkably remarkably easy to
navigate you can quickly see all the
parts available
for your vehicle and choose the brands
specifications and prices you prefer
rockauto.com is everything from engine
control modules and brake parts to tail
lamps motor oil even new carpet whether
it's for a classic or your daily driver
you get everything you need in a few
easy clicks delivered directly to your
door recorder comm it's a family
business serving Auto Parts customers
online for 20 years check them out at
Rock Auto calm the internet makes
everything better it makes everything
cheaper it makes everything more
competitive including your auto parts go
to Rock Auto calm right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
right Shapiro's in there how did you
hear about us box so they know that we
sent you that is Rock Auto calm again
right shapiro and their how did you hear
about us box rockauto.com all of this
has prompted people on in the rest of
the Democratic Party to attack Bernie as
being too radical and to attack Bernie
supporters because remember back in 2016
there were a lot of accusations that the
Bernie bros were toxic that they were
awful online which they are and that
they are they are radical and insane so
Michael Bloomberg cut an ad against
Bernie Sanders questioning the Bernie
bros and their sort of treatment of the
various other candidates online and
saying if you think that Bernie is the
guy who's gonna bring the party together
you're insane yelling at all the other
candidates from from Bernie supporters
are you being harassed by a Bernie bro
or a Bernie bot The Daily Dot Bernie's
angry boss New York Times his Bernie
Sanders is angry are me really what
Democrats want different views to be
able to engage in a civil discourse and
says really okay and this is basically
correct I mean inside the Democratic
Party
Bernie's people are known as the most
vicious the least tolerant the most
willing to attack other people the
roughest people online so Bloomberg
going after that and saying listen if
you want a unity candidate named Bernie
Sanders it's not actually a horrible
pitch it sounds kind of like a weak
pitch but it's inside the Democratic
Party it's not a horrible pitch
Bloomberg by the way is bidding for
eight for a sort of unity candidate vibe
now that unity candidate vibe was
exacerbated over the weekend by a report
that was put out by Drudge and that
suggested that Bloomberg is actively
considering picking up Hillary Clinton
as his running mate now this was made
fun of widely there were there were a
lot of people who are saying
that's that's ridiculous why would
Michael Bloomberg link himself with
Hillary Clinton who's off-putting and
polarizing and all the rest this is
about honestly it's about the smartest
thing that Bloomberg chem could leak
it's smart for two reasons one Hillary
was the last Democrat to unify the party
right she did it in 2016 and she won the
popular vote and she lost the electoral
college but she won the popular vote too
there are a lot of Democrats who believe
that she was legitimately elected and
who've been fulminating against the
electoral college ever since and who are
fascinated with the idea of Hillary
Clinton revenge voting right if
Hillary's on the ballot they get to go
vote for Hillary in order to push back
against Trump also Trump would then make
the entire canted about Hillary not
about Bloomberg right which which
Bloomberg would be fine with because
Hillary's the VP candidate would be this
weird spectacle of the president in one
party attacking the VP candidate in the
other party as opposed to the guy at the
top of the ticket so for all the talk
about how this is somehow dumb excuse me
it is not dumb in the slightest it's
actually quite smart Drudge had had
received the leak it's at exclusive
Bloomberg considers Hillary running mate
the tweet continued sources close to
Bloomberg campaign tell Drudge Report
that candidate is considering Hillary as
running mate after their polling found
the Bloomberg Clinton combo would be a
formidable force it's also a smart move
because Hillary Clinton is much more
likely to lend her support to a
candidate early on than his Barack Obama
so one of the big problems for Joe Biden
is that Barack Obama has basically been
absent I remember early on in this
campaign Biden said yeah I asked Joe I
asked Brock not to get involved because
I wanted to do this on my own I was like
yeah sure you did sure you did well that
was not true right obviously Barack
Obama didn't get involved because he
didn't want to be involved he was he
looked down like Rorschach at the city
and said no a Barack Obama was not
interested in the slightest in helping
Joe Biden but Hillary has not ruled out
running with Bloomberg which again gives
a bit of credence to Bloomberg running
to Democrat there's been a lot of talk
about Bloomberg being too much of a
Republican too much of an independent
he's not really a Democrat which is
weird because Bernie isn't really a
Democrat either right I mean the guy's
still a registered independents in the
state of Vermont but with all of that
said him kind of looking for this unity
mantle as Biden appears to be collapsing
into dust is fairly smart
Jason Schecter the campaign's
communication director said
we are focused on the primary in the
debate not VP speculation which is not a
denial that's not a denial a lot of
Republicans were celebrating that they
were suggesting that that oh good let's
have Hillary back on her and we can
campaign on Hillary that's not how this
works no one cares about VP candidates
except the people who are excited by the
VP candidate attacking VP candidates is
not particularly useful okay in a second
we're gonna get to Michael Bloomberg who
as I say is jumping in the polls and who
is also prepping to enter the debate
stage for the first time this week we'll
get to that momentarily first let us
talk about how you can save money and
you can do it easily and it's for free I
mean this is a great great thing I'm
talking of course about honey so I shop
online all the time as you may have
noticed I talk all the time about
shopping online buying things online
well what honey does is it browses the
web the interwebs for all of the promo
codes that I could be looking for in
searching for and instead just
automatically applies them and saves me
time and saves me money honey is the
free online shopping tool that
automatically finds the best promo codes
and applies them to your cart it feels
great to save using honey saving with
honey feels like sliding onto the seat
on a train just before the doors close I
mean it is just easy and simple and
again it you just install it on your
computer runs in the background of a
computer it fills in the promo codes and
it saves you money what could be better
than that it's easy why wouldn't you do
this exactly did you know that honey
supports over 30,000 stores online that
includes Macy's Target store for a Best
Buy and more they're adding more every
single day I probably saved at this
point I would imagine thousands of
dollars using honey they find you these
actual real discounts and they're used
to automatically apply them anytime you
buy something when you install it on
your computer and it just runs you don't
even think about it just saves you cash
it is free to use it installs in just a
few seconds get honey for free and join
honey calm slash spend this is like free
money guys join honey calm slash pen
that is Jo i N honey calm slash man join
honey calm slash pen okay so speaking of
Bloomberg and all the rest of Bloomberg
has now qualified for the upcoming
Democratic presidential debates
according to the Associated Press it
marks the first time he will stand
alongside the rivals he has so far
avoided by bypassing the early voting
states and using his personal fortune to
define himself through TV ads there's a
new NPR PBS Maris Paul published Tuesday
it shows
with 19% support nationally in the
Democratic nominating process
it's a dangerous move for him to be on
stage because obviously he's gonna be
the target of all the attacks but that
also makes him the center of attention
and that's not terrible for Bloomberg
now what's he gonna be hit with the
answer is all the things he's going to
be hit with every single thing Kevin
Shiki is his campaign manager says Mike
is looking forward to joining the other
Democratic candidates on stage making
the case for why he's the best candidate
to defeat Trump and unite the country
now there are a couple of attacks that
he's certainly going to experience right
you're gonna get the Bernie Sanders
well he's look up to him he's a billion
that he's a billion that buying his way
in here he's trying to bide the
nomination
Bloomberg's gonna say and in a general
election you're gonna be going up
against a billionaire don't you want
somebody who has not beholden to anybody
who's gonna be able to sign all the
checks necessary in order to defeat
Donald Trump don't you want that you've
complained about Pete Budaj raising
money from billionaires and you're right
he's subject to their whims and Bernie
you know you talk about how you are
going to raise a raise a general amounts
of money from the population you really
think you're gonna be able to rival a
guy who's worth a billion dollars
and she's gonna be cashing in all of his
chips because you're cuz you're a
communist right every person on Wall
Street will sign him attract hey I'm the
only person on the stage who's gonna be
able to compete with Donald Trump in the
spending race not a bad pitch seriously
not a bad pitch you know Michael
Bloomberg is worth sixty three billion
dollars sixty three billion dollars also
Joe Biden might say to him well what
exactly has he ever accomplished I was
vice president
well Bloomberg on the campaign trail has
been saying about Joe Biden that Joe
Biden just read speech other people read
speeches other people wrote for him fair
and accurate okay about about peabody
judge who will be saying we need a new
blood michael bloomberg isn't really a
democrat he's gonna be saying you're a
mayor of a small town that's literally
what he says he just he goes on the
campaign trail isis Budi judges mayor of
a small town so here's what's happening
people are freaked out by bloomberg on
the left side of the party and the other
quote-unquote moderates are afraid that
bloomberg is going to crowd them out and
so they have been dropping every piece
of apple they can find on michael
bloomberg some have been some of these
pieces of Oppo are damaging to Bloomberg
some of these pieces of Apple are not
quite as damaging to Bloomberg it is
telling which ones the Democrats think
are damaging and which ones they think
are not damaging so
they're a bunch of clips of Bloomberg
that are now going around and again it
is kind of impressive to see how the
Democrats ranked which ones are damaging
to Bloomberg versus which ones are not
so let's take one that I think would be
damaging to Bloomberg but actually
nobody seems to be playing with okay so
just a couple of years ago Bloomberg was
talking about open borders now normally
this would be like a Bernie home run
right Bernie would just say listen we
can't have open borders we can't have
people swamp in our borders because I
want to socialist America and in order
to have a socialist America we have to
take care of the people qua keya
all right that's actually heading with
trumpian approach Bernie has now revised
that and he says he wants to get rid of
ice and Border Patrol according to AOC
but
Bloomberg back in 2016 was making the
case for open borders now normally this
would be a pretty damning indictment in
a primary you would think but in the
Democratic Party this stuff is
considered non-controversial then we'll
get to the stuff considered
controversial here's Bloomberg circa
2016 the world is more complex than ever
before it is more dangerous than ever
before because of technology and weapons
and that sort of thing and free travel
and that sort of thing but the solution
to our problems is more open borders not
closed borders the solution to our
problem is to improve education not to
try to penalize people because they are
successful if you don't have successful
people you're never gonna have the
wherewithal to support to help those who
are not we've tried socialism it doesn't
work okay so so that is Michael
Bloomberg in the open border stuff that
theoretically would be damaging in the
primary but the Democrats consider that
part uncontroversial we get to the parts
that they consider controversial
in just one second first let's talk
about some simple facts you wouldn't
leave your front door unlocked
somebody might rob your house even
though that is unlikely it could happen
you wouldn't leave your car unlocked
because somebody could rob your car
again unlikely but it certainly could
happen you can leave your bathroom door
unlocked when we have small children
because they will walk in on you okay
that's much more likely to happen but
the fact is you should be locking up
your internet usage because your data
belongs to you why would you allow
somebody else access to it this is why
you need a VPN I've been using a VPN for
years you should too the best VPN on the
market for my money Express VPN did you
know that your internet service provider
knows every single website you visit
well expressvpn
helps protect your internet activity
from those ISPs what's worse they can
sell that
information to add companies and tech
giants who will use that data to target
you expressvpn puts a stop to it it
creates a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet so
your online activity cannot be seen by
anyone expressvpn works on everything
phones laptops even routers everyone who
shares their Wi-Fi can still be
protected even if they don't even have
expressive VPN the best part is using
expressvpn it's as easy as closing the
bathroom door or locking your front door
you just install it on your computer
runs in the background doesn't slow down
your internet it is quick it is safe it
is easy and doesn't cost you a lot of
money go check them out right now at
expressvpn comm slash been today use my
exclusive link expressive VPN comm slash
ban exp ress VPN comm slash Ben you get
an extra three months for free that's
expressvpn comm slash pen okay we'll get
to more of the oppo dropping on Michael
Bloomberg in just one second first I
want to take a moment to thank all of
our daily wire members the people who
support our message to read our news who
keep us independent and honest we love
making content that matters and while
we're on the frontlines of the culture
war we cannot do it without you so if
you haven't jumped on the daily wear
party bus a readers pass it's a great
way to dip your toe into the community
if you're obsessed with news a readers
pass will enable you to read our article
sad free including my op-eds which are
exclusive for daily wear Members Only
it's a great way to stay in touch with
breaking news and in-depth analysis from
a conservative perspective the readers
pass is a great value for the money it
really is and it gets you into a
community of like-minded political
junkies you also get access to our
mobile app which has really been taking
off since we launched it in September of
last year you can read all of our
stories on mobile additionally you can
also receive push notifications for
breaking news and special content which
is perfect for one you want to stay
up-to-date on the go
membership tier is already a bargain at
3 bucks a month 3 bucks a month if
you're hesitant you should check out our
special offer right now we are offering
one month of our readers our readers
version for $0.99 that's mobile ad free
access to all of daily Wired news
exclusive op-eds
from me and breaking news and updates on
our mobile app all for the low price of
$1 give it a shot I think you will be
hooked otherwise go get our more
expensive membership and you get access
to everything which is even better but
you can give us a shot right now for
like $0.99 and get that readers access
it really is fantastic you're listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
so Michael Bloomberg that clip about him
talking open borders that ain't gonna
damage him with the Democrats let's get
to the stuff that will damage him with
the Democrats so there there are a few
things one there are all these old clips
that are now popping up of Michael
Bloomberg as a general rule I don't
think that old clips tend to hurt
candidates as much as they used to
because the fact is the Donald Trump got
hit with every old clip he had said and
it didn't matter one iota if people
believe they know you then they're not
going to change their mind about you
because of an old clip that's just the
way that this works right you can
uncover everything Bernie ever said his
people will still say they love him
doesn't matter what you say about him
they're doing the same thing about
Bloomberg now Bloomberg may be uniquely
susceptible to this in the sense that he
has morphed over time and he seems
completely chameleon akin terms of his
politics he will take all of the things
that he did ten years ago brag about
them for eight years and then the last
two years decide that he's gonna throw
them under the bus like his
stop-and-frisk stuff hey but some of the
clips that are now coming out from him
it there's no question that Bernie is
emptying the vault and it's got to be
Bernie right this is not Biden this is
Bernie who is dumping out the vault on
Bloomberg so let's take clip number one
here's hit with one two three four five
clips that are apparently supposed to be
super damaging to him over the weekend
clip number one Bloomberg was apparently
lamenting and job prospects for black
and Hispanic youth and he was talking
about why black and Hispanic uses an
interview form I think 2011 he was
talking about why black and Hispanic
youths are having a tough time in the
job market there's this enormous cohort
of black and Latino males aged let's say
16 to 25 that don't have jobs don't have
any prospects don't know how to find
jobs don't know that they what their
skill sets are don't know how to behave
in the workplace where they have EE okay
so that the last line ray says they
don't know how to behave in the
workplace has been taking in as well
this means that he's being a racist well
he didn't say all the Latino kids don't
know how to behave in the workplace so
he's saying right there I mean it's it's
amazing that I've now become like the
person who tries to contextualize what
Bloomberg is saying but I feel like so
many of these Apple hits lately are
really out of context okay what
Bloomberg is saying there if you were
saying all the tea no kids don't know
how to act in the workplace that's
ridiculous that would be racist okay
that's not what he is saying there what
he is saying is there's a cohort of
young people 16 to 25 who have high
rates of
because they don't have the right
education because they don't know how to
behave in the workplace and don't make
good employees because they don't know
that because of lack of education
because they're maybe not fathers in the
home thank you
that seems fairly uncontroversial but
this has become a big talking point say
so that was clip number one is they're
trying to paint Bloomberg is a racist
that's not working particularly well at
least in the polls thus far
remember they tried this the other day
over his stop and frisk comments where
he's talking about stop and frisk in New
York City and I said I was doubtful that
was gonna have a major impact so I was
clip number one there's clip number two
they're going after Bloomberg for saying
that cuts to Medicare are a thing that
must be a part of deficit reduction now
again I don't think this is gonna have
any significant impact because frankly
it's perfectly reasonable of course cuts
to Medicare and Social Security are
going to happen or you're gonna have to
dramatically escalate axes within the
next five to ten years but Bloomberg is
saying here is not super controversial
and again who exactly is gonna get off
the Bloomberg train at this point
against Bernie Sanders if this is aimed
at old people and saying to old people
that Bernie is gonna take better care of
you and Michael Bloomberg well old
people don't like Bernie why cuz they
remember communism and it's not great
then remember socialism in the world it
isn't fantastic so that that attack
isn't gonna play so I don't think the
doubt that earlier attack is gonna play
I don't think this attack is gonna play
either here is Bloomberg talking about
deficit reduction keep in mind no
program to reduce the deficit is makes
any sense whatsoever
unless you address the issue of
entitlements Medicare Medicaid Social
Security interest payment on the debt
which I can't touch and defense spending
everything else is tiny compared to that
this is of course 100% true so if
they're dumping that at their Zappa
that's not gonna make any difference
either so you've got the attack that
he's a racist that is not playing so
much then there is the attack that he
was once conservative fiscally that's
not gonna play so much because everybody
with an iota of brains understands this
and also like again you think older
Americans feel more sanguine with an
actual communist in charge not so much
then there's the attack on Bloomberg
because there's a clip of Bloomberg
talking about the treatment of cancer
when you're 95 years old and the
suggestion is that he wants to old
people to die something with apparently
a bunch of Orthodox Jews in this
particular clip here's Bloomberg talking
about talking about government base to
treatment of older people that's a rate
we're going health care was gonna
bankrupt
so not only do we have a problem it's
gonna back loose and we've gotta sit
here and say which things were gonna do
and which things were not nobody wants
to do that you know you show up with
prostate cancer you're 95 years old we
should say go and enjoy have a nice live
a long life yeah okay Bloomberg is
getting hit over this the suggestion
that we should be dumping out resources
on somebody who is 95 years old of it's
government-run health care two things
one in a government-run health care
system Bloomberg is exactly right in a
non government-run health care system if
you're 95 and you wish to shell out for
prostate cancer first of all let me be
clear about this you know many doctors
would recommend prostate surgery for a
95 year old the answer is zero okay
really if you're 95 years old you get
prostate cancer this is in really this
example is typically used by doctors as
a case where you would say the treatment
is worse than the is worse than the no
treatment right because prostate cancer
is typically slow-moving it could take
five to ten years to kill you you're 95
already so you have past life expectancy
already that means that the chances of
you dying on the operating table when
you're 95 years old are much higher than
the chances of you just spending the
next five years and of gradually dying a
prostate cancer but being okay for maybe
three of those five years right that is
that's like typical medical example
trying to try that out as an example of
Boerne of michael bloomberg being unkind
to seniors his kind of ridiculous but
even in the government health care
context if you don't let question for
Democrats if you don't like that answer
from Michael Bloomberg if you don't like
that answer may ask why the hell you're
calling for publicly for publicly run
government health care do you really
think there's a lot of government-run
health care systems that are giving
prostate surgeries to 95 year olds
really because private systems you could
write to me for 95 you wanna pay for it
and you make that call you can but do
you really think that a lot of
government-run health care systems are
not rationing care for older people on
behalf of younger people this has
literally talked about Ezekiel Emanuel
who's Rahm Emmanuel's brother and one of
the fathers of Obamacare he literally
wrote a piece in the Atlantic titled why
I want to die before I'm 80 right and it
was it was the whole thing was about
this it was about how once you hit 80
your health starts to deteriorate maybe
we should just say to people that you've
live
full life farewell at 80 okay now life
expectancy is like 81 for women in the
United States and I know a lot of really
healthy old people who are like 80 thank
God but both my grandfather's have
passed away but thank God both my
grandmother's are still alive one of
them is 90 and one of them is 94 94 I
believe okay and good for them but what
Blumberg saying there is again medically
uncontroversial but this is being
trotted out as evidence that Bloomberg
doesn't like old people or something
okay that is a fail as well okay then
finally they get to a clip that they
think is super damaging for Bloomberg
both Republicans and Democrats
suggesting this is super damaging for
Bloomberg because they're saying this is
Bloomberg looking down on farmers and
industrial workers so I want to play the
entire clip because you're getting a
sort of the 15-second version where he
says that farming is about poking holes
in the dirt and putting seeds in them or
working a or working a lathe if you are
an industrial if you're an industrial
worker here's the full clip of what
Michael Bloomberg is saying and then we
can analyze just how bad it is we're
just more and more if you think about
the agrarian society lasted 3000 years
and we could teach processes I could
teach anybody even people in this room
just don't know offence intended to be a
farmer you it's a process you dig a hole
you put up a seed in you put dirt on top
add water up comes the corn then we had
300 you could learn that then then you
have 300 years of the industrial society
you put the piece of metal on the lathe
you turn the crank and the direction of
the arrow and you can have a job and we
created a lot of jobs one point 98
percent of the world worked in in
agriculture today it's 2 percent in the
United States
now comes the information economy and
the information economy is fundamentally
different because it's built around
replacing people with technology and the
skill sets that you have to learn are
how to think and analyze and that is a
whole degree level different ok so
people are saying this is him ripping on
farmers and ripping on industrial
workers that is a hundred percent now
what he's doing there can I point this
out like just to be an honest human
being
he is not saying that today's farmers
who are working in highly mechanized in
highly regimented
industries that today's agricultural
workers people who are running farms and
figuring out not just the crop cycles
but exactly where is the best place to
place to plant what sort of fertilizer
has to be used
what sort of chemicals have to be used
how to fix the machinery how to create
supply lines how to ensure that the
marketing matches the product right I
mean that's a very complex that's not
what he was talking about he literally
makes that statement time-bound he
literally makes the statement time-bound
he says for he's talking about the
transferability of people in a new-age
economy what kind of education is
necessary he's not saying a farmer today
can't learn to be somebody who codes
tomorrow what he is saying is that it
was easier to integrate people into more
rudimentary jobs a thousand years ago
and it is to integrate people into more
sophisticated jobs today by the way I'm
sure that if you asked Bloomberg would
it be easy to take a person who is just
you know a Jewish guy from the from from
Brooklyn right guy who grew up in
Brooklyn and just make him a farmer
tomorrow on a farm would that be easy
his answer be no that's a sophisticated
business rather sophisticated business
you actually have to sit and you have to
learn the business that's not a thing
that's easy because even agriculture is
an information age agriculture that's
what's happening in modern society now
right he literally makes it time-bound
you just I hate to be the fact-checker
here but the fact is he says for 3,000
years you were either in an agricultural
job or you weren't in a job and those
jobs were a lot more rudimentary than
the jobs now then he says in the
industrial for 300 years people could
get into these sort of rudimentary jobs
or work in a factory and you worked a
lathe and if you get a job and so
getting in or out of the job wasn't all
that difficult now you have to have
years of education in order to educate
people for jobs because we live in an
Information Age that applies to industry
and agriculture and computers and
pharmaceuticals and all the other stuff
people are taking this out of context
Republicans and Democrats to suggest
that he's anti farmer or something maybe
an effective attack because taking
people out of context is very effective
but how have I become the Bloomberg
defender here is just wild then so there
are two groups of people who are
attacking Bloomberg here okay but
they're the far left who are attacking
Bloomberg the Sanders cites for
attacking Bloomberg dishonestly and then
there's the the right-wing attacking
Bloomberg I would say mostly
expeditiously
right they're just doing so out of
expedience they're doing so
they think that Bloomberg is more
dangerous in a general election than
Sanders now let me just make my
preference is clear here because I'm up
front about my biases I would
significantly prefer to see Michael
Bloomberg as the Democratic nominee than
Bernie Sanders why number one I don't
think Bloomberg this is strong least
advertised nationally I think in
Bloomberg is a New York billionaire I
think Donald Trump is a New York
billionaire I think Trump has a more
visceral connection with people in the
Midwest than Michael Bloomberg does I
think that Donald Trump speaks with a
more populist two tone it than Michael
Bloomberg I don't think that Bloomberg
is nearly as strong as some people in
the Republican Party apparently fear he
is that's number one I'm not sure that
Bloomberg is all that much stronger than
Bernie but let's even assume that
Bloomberg is a stronger candidate in a
general election than Bernie I said
earlier in the program in a general
election I would give 60/40 odds on
president Trump beating Mike beating
Bernie Sanders let's say that those odds
are fifty five forty five for Trump
against Michael Bloomberg yeah that he
has slightly better odds of beating
Sanders than he does of beating
Bloomberg I would still prefer Bloomberg
as the Democratic nominee because the
downside risk of a Bloomberg presidency
is not the same as the downside risk of
Bernie Sanders presidency it is not in
fact the downside risk of a Bloomberg
candidacy is not the same as the
downside risk of a Sanders candidacy it
is not good for America when the
Democratic Party is the party of Jeremy
Corbyn as opposed to the party as
opposed to the party of Tony Blair it is
not good for America when the Democratic
Party is the party of Ilhan Omar and
Rasheeda Talib as opposed to the party
of Dianne Feinstein and scoop Jackson
aye
I want a democratic party that is still
bound by the realm of sanity I would
prefer that so if you're out there
actively rooting for a Bernie Sanders
candidacy and you're tearing down
Michael Bloomberg dishonestly because
that's what you're looking for here and
you're a Democrat you're doing that
first of all I would suggest you're
acting in bad faith if you're Republican
you're doing that I think you're being
short-sighted because here's the thing
we live in a two-party system there's no
such thing as eternal dominance for one
party the Democrats learned this in 2016
and Republicans learned this all the way
back in 2006 I remember after 2004 when
george w bush won reelection and one
additional seats in the house and in the
senate i remember i wrote a column in
2005 saying well maybe republicans will
never lose again the next year they got
swamped in congress hey America is a
pendulum and just because it swings in
the right direction for a little while
does not mean it's not
to swing equivalently in the wrong
direction the other way so you should
prefer as a as a common sense American
you should prefer a democratic party
that is not in thrall to an old commie
like Bernie Sanders nonetheless you're
starting to see the the Democrats who
are not centrist mobilizing around
burning again do you really want this
party it scares the hell out of me do
you really want a party that is run by
Bill DeBlasio and ill hen Omar and
Rashid it's leading Bernie Sanders that
way one hears Bill DeBlasio going after
Michael Bloomberg saying Bloomberg is
the epitome of the power structure first
of all I just want to point something
out whenever you hear communists like
Bill DeBlasio talk about the
quote/unquote epitome of the power
structure Michael Bloomberg built a
business he did not grow up with
billions of dollars
he built a business that employs tens of
thousands of people that is not the
epitome of the power structure the
epitome of the power structures being a
useless groundhog murderer like Bill
DeBlasio and then somehow ending up as
mayor of New York where you horribly run
the subway system and ensure that trash
is back on the streets that's the
epitome of the power structure being
successful in private industry is not
the power structure being in charge of a
government that can run the lives of
tens of millions of people that's the
power structure hillsboro here's Bill
DeBlasio however stumping for Bernie
Michael Bloomberg represents the status
quo and it's important to talk about it
he is using an inordinate amount of
money we've never seen anything like it
in the history of the United States but
what it is masking is a lifetime of
supporting those in power he is the
epitome of the power structure in this
country and it's important for people to
start understanding what he's really
about given that he's spending literally
hundreds of millions of dollars to
portray only one side of the story okay
so you've got the Communists in the in
the Democratic Party the Bill de
Blasio's who again literally was a
communist and Bernie Sanders who
literally was a communist against
Michael Bloomberg and then you got Joe
Biden and Joe Biden is basically just
trying to cling to life at this point
he's echoing the same messages by the
way that Michael Bloomberg is echoing
and his messages are correct he's saying
Bernie's a Democratic Socialist do we
really want that at the top of the
Democratic Party here is Burt here's
Biden ripping on Bernie correctly the
voters in the Democratic primary have
one overarching desire to beat Donald
Trump and who's most likely to beat him
is a former Republican who just turned
Democrat most likely to defeat Donald
Trump is it's Bernie a Democratic
Socialist good guys he most likely to
defeat Donald Trump who's most likely to
defeat Donald Trump okay so his rip on
Sanders is is correct there's only one
problem which is the Biden is pretty
much out of it at this point I mean
literally he doesn't remember where he
is who's in Nevada and said he was in
California the other day so that means
that Bloomberg is person most likely to
pick up the pieces meanwhile Barack
Obama is staying out right the only
person who can save Barack Oh a boat who
can save Joe Biden is Barack Obama and
ain't happening it's not happening at
all but meanwhile Donald Trump is out
there campaigning and as long as here's
the thing as long as Donald Trump does
not defeat Donald Trump everything's
gonna be okay
Trump pissed everybody off over the
weekend because he went to the Daytona
500 was given a hero's welcome here it
wasn't the Daytona 500 International
Speedway we love our country and it's
truly an honor to be with all of you at
the great American race gentlemen start
your engines
[Applause]
so that look Trump as long as Trump
doesn't a few Trump Trump's gonna be in
good shape against whoever the field in
the Democratic Party is so you know
let's let's desperately hope that Trump
controls himself because that Democratic
Party continues to be a bleep show okay
time for a couple of things I like and
then we'll do a couple of things that I
hate so things that I like today over
the weekend again my wife and I in
preparation for baby number three were
relaxing with dummy action movies from
the 1990s this one is actually not that
dumb it's not that dumb actually we'll
kind of a thing that I found out I
didn't realize the deeds so the movies
the Air Force one it is the best of the
1990s action flicks Air Force One is
fantastic all right first of all
Harrison Ford is great second well Gary
Oldman is just a phenomenal actor Gary
Oldman is great in everything he's
chilling in this movie he really is as
the as the Russian terrorists it really
is great what's amazing about this film
if you watch Air Force One today the
patriotism of the film is almost
overwhelming it really is like we would
not make a film like this today in
America to make an openly patriotic film
like this would be unbelievable the film
opens with the United States
participating in the kidnapping and
imprisonment of a foreign leader with
the killing of Qasem Soleimani basically
I mean it really opens with u.s. special
forces going into Kazakhstan and
capturing a communist a communist
dictator of Kazakhstan and handing him
over to the Russians for imprisonment
so that Kazakhstan can become more
democratic and then and then Harrison
Ford getting up as president of the US
and making a speech at a dinner where he
says no longer are we going to let pure
American realist foreign policy
considerations decide what we ought to
do when there's a human rights violation
the United States is going to step in
and do something about it he sounds like
george w bush circa 2002 it really is
incredible right and he's the hero over
the film he's the hero of the film the
amazing sort of ambition that the United
States had in the aftermath of the Cold
War is on full display in Air Force One
also the villain in this movie is no I'm
Chomsky so the villain in this movie is
a Russian terrorist who wants the
reconstitution of the Soviet Union and
who is just reading from Howard Zinn
heal it there's one point at which he's
accused of being a terrorist because he
takes over Air Force One kills a bunch
of civilians and he says you call me a
terrorist well you the President of the
United States you've killed a hundred
thousand Iraqis over oil
and you call me the terrorist I mean
it's like pure Bernie Sanders he's not a
line but I swear there's not a line that
Gary Oldman says is the villain in Air
Force one that would not come from
Bernie Sanders rally except for the
whole killing of the hostages thing
anyway that is pretty amazing the film
itself thing I didn't know about it
Randy Newman was originally slated to do
the score they didn't like the scores
then went to Jerry Goldsmith he's one of
the great film scorers in film history
he wrote the entire score for Air Force
One in 12 days under time crunch I heard
a little bit of the preview and isn't
making this decision as a president he's
making it as a husband and a father
let's not forget this president as a
Medal of Honor winner he knows how to
fight
he has no right to take chances with his
life
cannot give in to their demands he's got
a job to do makes me so proud mr.
president would you stuck with us
no your father he is also nothing like
my father
we're tracking six mix I'm sending in
our f-15s to protect you
six
people died my family don't ask me for
something I can't do I'm joking
but only a little I have a feeling the
Bernie watches this and he's rooting for
the bad guys hey I mean really like Gary
Oldman is gonna like reconstitute the
Soviet Union and he's talking about how
evil the United States is and how u.s.
interventionism around the world has
caused every major crisis and that this
movie is so overwhelmingly patriotic I'm
not sure it could get made anymore
really because the the perspective that
Americans have on America is so jaded
and cynical at this point that I think
there are a huge number of Americans who
watch this movie and they would be like
are we even allowed to talk about the
country this way anymore we should watch
it because it is it is fascinating to
watch sort of almost as sort of an a
coded an Amber and preserved for history
moment in time what the u.s. thought of
itself circa about 1997 because remember
this made by liberals in Hollywood in
1997 and then watch that with an eye
toward what it is now and it is a pretty
impressive change a really impressive
change I mean it the change in the
Democratic Party since 1996 and now is
just insane I mean I've lived through it
it's been it's been incredible okay
another thing that I like over the
weekend Democrats tried to pass an
assault weapons ban in Virginia fail
fail so that remember that time that it
was supposed to be an act of terrorism
for the Republicans and for for
conservatives all over Virginia to come
to Richmond and in full compliance with
the law open carry it was gonna be the
end of the world when that turns out
that even Democrats in the Virginia
assembly weren't willing to go along
with their own plan according to the
Washington Post Democrats who won
control of Virginia's legislature on the
promise of sweeping gun control lost a
battle over assault-style weapons on
Monday hen and Governor Ralph Northam a
big defeat and giving a rare win to
second item in activists in the newly
blue Capitol a Virginia Senate committee
killed a bill that would have banned the
sale of assault style weapons and
possession of high-capacity magazines it
had been a top priority for Northam a
former Army doctor who served in
Operation Desert Storm and an often no
mark she has seen first handled weapons
of war Duty human beings love that
editorializing they're from the
Washington Post
they don't say had been a top priority
for governor Ralph Northam also known as
man from his high school days the
bill was part of a package of eight gun
control measures nor them advanced after
shooter killed 12 people at a Virginia
Beach Municipal Building on May 31st
Republicans refusal tax on
Bill's last summer became a rallying cry
for Democrats in November elections they
flipped the State House and Senate blue
for the first time in a generation that
had very little to do with the with the
gun control proposals the Democrats were
pushing it had a lot more to do with the
fact that Republicans just got swamped
across the board in November of 2018 the
house has passed all eight of northern
bills but a handful of Democrats in the
less liberal Senate have quashed three
of them amid fears that the newly
empowered party might overplay its hand
the same tension has been playing out on
other fronts with the Senate taking a
more cautious approach on issues like
minimum wage collective bargaining and
state budgeting because even the
Democrats in Virginia recognize that if
they go too radical too fast it's gonna
be a disaster for them so a defeat for
governor Ralph Northam the people of
Virginia get to keep their assault
weapons and continue to purchase them
this is a this is a strong move by the
pro Second Amendment lobby in Virginia
and a big loss for governor Ralph
Northam okay we would do things I hate
but we have run out of time so instead
come here later today for two additional
hours of content otherwise we will see
you here tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
Whitehouse key technical producer Austin
Stephens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam sy events audio
is mixed by Mike Cora Mina
hair and makeup is by Anika Geneva the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2020
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]